[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland eurem truecrime Podcast von
Welt mein Name ist Toni Heyer und ich
bin Mirko Kasimir heute berichten wir
über den Mord an der Studentin Meredith
culture eine Mordfall von dem jeder der
sich für true Prime interessiert sicher
schon gehört haben dürfte ja und die
meisten anderen auch aber auch wenn ihr
schon davon gehört habt denke ich dass
ihr diesen Fall nach der Folge
vielleicht mit anderen Augen sehen
werdet der Engel mit den eiskalten Augen
so nannte die Presse immer in der Knox
und ja wir werden viel über Amanda Knox
reden denn das ist ein besonderer Fall
weil es ein ewiges hin und her gab über
die Frage schuldig oder nicht und selbst
als die vermeintliche Täterin
freigesprochen wurde gab es Leute die
das nicht akzeptiert haben na und manche
haben es bis heute nicht akzeptiert aber
mal gucken passt doch mal ganz kurz
zusammen also Spoiler mal die ganze
Story bevor wir uns jetzt im Detail
angucken
am 1 November 2007 wurde die britische
Austauschstudentin Meredith culture in
Perugia Italien ermordet sie hieß
Anzeichen von sexueller Gewalt und
Stichverletzungen auf die Ermittlungen
konzentrierten sich schnell auf Meredith
Mitbewohnerin Amanda Knox und ihren
damaligen Freund oder faeliso sowie
einen dritten Verdächtigen Rudi quäder
wurde 2008 rechtskräftig als Täter
verurteilt solicitor und Knox wurden
wegen mitterschaft zu langen Haftstrafen
verurteilt später wurde das Urteil gegen
die beiden aufgehoben sie wurden frei
gesprochen in der nächsten Instanz wurde
immer der Knox erneut für schuldig
befunden und bekam eine noch höhere
Haftstrafe schließlich landete der Fall
vor dem höchsten italienischen Gericht
und endete mit einem endgültigen
Freispruch zu diesem Zeitpunkt hatte er
immer in der Knox bereits mehr als 4
Jahre abgesessen ganz wichtig auch es
war kein Freispruch aus Mangel an
Beweisen oder sowas sondern wegen
erwiesener Unschuld sie saß also für
nichts im Gefängnis aber schauen wir uns
einmal an wie sie dahin gekommen ist
von der viadelle Pergola in Perugia der
Hauptstadt der italienischen Provinz
Umbrien hat man einen wunderbaren Blick
ins Tal bis hinüber nach Monte laguaria
nicht weit entfernt liegt der
beeindruckende etruskische Bogen ein
Stadttor aus dem dritten Jahrhundert vor
Christus mit mächtigen Wachttürmen
gleich dahinter beginnt die Altstadt mit
ihren verwinkelten Gassen
Italien wie aus dem Bilderbuch das
kleine Haus mit der Nummer 7 an der Via
de La Pergola duckt sich an den Hang und
wäre der perfekte Airbnb Sport während
da nicht die Straße und die Betonmauer
hinter dem Haus ja aber wen juckt das
schon wenn man jung ist und als Student
im Ausland
die Britin Meredith culture dies 21
Jahre alt und studiert italienisch und
europäische Politik als sie zu einem
Austauschjahr nach Perugia kommt in der
Via de La Pergola ist ein vegzimmer frei
am 20 September zieht Meredith zu der
20-Jährigen Amerikanerin Amanda Knox und
ihren italienischen Mitbewohnerin
Filomena Romanelli und Laura
Meredith ist freundlich offen und
beliebt eine hübsche junge Frau mit
strahlendem Lächeln und voller
Enthusiasmus für Italien seine Kultur
und Sprache für ihr Studium das
Austauschjahr soll die Zeit ihres Lebens
werden die Zeit ihres Lebens dauerte
keine sechs Wochen der erste november
2007 ist ein Feiertag in Italien viele
Männer und Laura also die beiden
italienischen Mitbewohnerinnen die sind
nicht in der Stadt am Ende ist bei ihrem
neuen Freund Raphaela und Meredith die
ist bei drei befreundeten Mädels aus
Großbritannien ien zum Abendessen
eingeladen gegen 3:45 Uhr ist sie
bereits auf dem Heimweg und
verabschiedet sich keine 500 m vor ihrem
Haus von einer Freundin diese Freundin
ist die letzte die Meredith lebend sieht
am Morgen des zweiten November kehrt
Amenda Heim nachdem sie die Nacht bei
Raffaele verbracht hat die Haustür der
Via della Pergola 7 steht offen im Bad
dass sie sich mit Meredith teilt findet
Amanda Blutstropfen sie will nach ihrer
Mitbewohnerin schauen doch deren
Zimmertür ist verschlossen vermutlich
schläft sie na was schon komisch
Blutstropfen im Bad warum ruft immer da
nicht die Polizei na ich vermute sie
wird sich schon gewundert haben aber für
ein paar bluttrocken im Bad ja da gibt
es alle möglichen Erklärungen ja das
stimmt auch wieder am Ende nimmt eine
Dusche und kurz danach wird ihr klar
dass ihr etwas überhaupt gar nicht
stimmt
denn im Bad von philomena und Laura da
findet sie noch etwas
ich weiß jetzt nicht wie ich das elegant
sagen soll aber also in der Toilette da
ist noch was jemand hat ganz
offensichtlich nicht gespült und Amanda
ist sich ziemlich sicher dass das nicht
Meredith gewesen sein kann Amanda läuft
zur Wohnung ihres Freundes kurz darauf
kehren die beiden gemeinsam zurück und
jetzt entdecken Sie noch etwas das
Fenster zu philomenas Schlafzimmer ist
eingeworfen das Zimmer ist verwüstet
alles ist durchwühlt und überall liegen
Scherben herum doch seltsamerweise
scheint nichts zu fehlen
Amanda und rafaele machen sich nun
ernsthaft Sorgen vor allem um Meredith
raphaele hämmert gegen ihre Tür und
versucht sie aufzubekommen doch ist
gelingt ihm nicht Amanda hat inzwischen
die Polizei gerufen ja und die kommt
schneller als erwartet denn zwei
Polizisten die waren schon unterwegs
nicht wegen des Einbruchs sondern weil
in der Nachbarschaft zwei Handys
gefunden und bei der Polizei abgegeben
wurden
dort hat man die Besitzerin ermitteln
können also mereditor aber warum zwei
Handys also in einem steckte die
SIM-Karte für Auslandsgespräche und das
andere ist für Gespräche im
italienischen Netz die beiden Beamten
wollten also wirklich nur die Handys
zurückgeben und vielleicht eine Anzeige
aufnehmen dann treffen auch philomena
und ein Freund ein Amanda hat die beiden
zuvor angerufen und alle verlangen von
dem Polizisten jetzt die Tür
aufzubrechen als die sich aber für nicht
zuständig erklären und auch Verstärkung
warten wollen da bricht philomenas
Freund die Tür mit drei Tritten auf
dann wird es für einen Moment ganz still
und dann dann schreit viele Männer
da sind Blutflecken auf dem Boden an der
Wand und auf einem Handtuch das auf dem
Bett liegt doch das ist es nicht was
viele Männer so erschreckt hat in einem
Interview mit dem Podcast crime Junkies
beschrieb am Ende noch später wie sie
diese Momente erlebt philomena hat
geschrien und es ist total durchgedreht
ich verstehe nicht was sie sagt ich höre
nur ein Fuß ein Fuß ich weiß nicht wovon
sie spricht ich denke okay sie hat einen
Fuß gesehen und sie ist eindeutig in
Panik
ist ein abgetrennter Fuß drin was ist
denn da los die Polizisten sagen sofort
raus aus dem Haus und ich versuche
herauszufinden was los ist weil alle
plötzlich im sehr schnellen
italienischen reden mitnimmt Zimmer
liegt eine dicke beige Daunendecke
ausgebreitet ein nackter Fuß schaut
darunter hervor sofort bringen die
Beamten alle nach draußen vor das Haus
und alarmieren die Mordkommission unter
der Decke finden sie die Leiche von
Meredith culture nackt von der Taille
abwärts mit einer großen messerwunde
unter dem Kinn und mehreren kleineren
Stichwunden am Hals
unter ihrem Körper liegen zwei
blutverschmierte Handtücher ein drittes
Handtuch und ihre blutverschmierte
Handtasche befinden sich auf dem Bett
ihre blutgetränke Kleidung liegt
ebenfalls auf dem Boden in der Nähe der
Leiche finden die Ermittler drei blutige
Schuhabdrücke die eine Spur zur Tür
bilden
[Musik]
Amanda steht vor dem Haus und es dauert
bis sie wirklich begreift was geschehen
ist Raffaele nimmt sie in den Arm die
beiden Kissen sich und das wird später
zu einem wichtigen Anklagepunkt gegen
sie werden also zumindest in den Augen
der Öffentlichkeit
dies Import die sehen sie als eiskalte
Killerin die ihre Mitbewohnerin ermordet
hat oder bzw die nach dem Mord ihrer
Mitbewohnerin nichts besseres zu tun hat
als ihren Freund zu küssen so nett war
tja und das ist natürlich Unsinn denn
wer von uns weiß schon wie er sich in so
einer Situation verhalten würde was
dieser Schock mit einem machen würde
vielleicht würde man versteinern
vielleicht würde man schreien oder sogar
in hysterisches Gelächter ausbrechen
sich da an die Arme des eigenen Freundes
zu flüchten das kommt mir nicht gerade
eiskalt vor ja voll auf Außenstehende
wirkt sich vielleicht ungerührt aber ich
meine niemand hat ja eine Ahnung was in
ihr vorgeht
viele Menschen die brauchen auch einfach
eine Weile bevor sie so ein verarbeitet
haben dass sie überhaupt checken was da
gerade passiert ist wenn so ein Schock
das ist ja auch ein schutzinstinktes
Körpers
die Autopsie von Meredith culture ergibt
mehrere Schnittwunden am Hals und an den
Händen Prellungen außerdem Verletzungen
im Genitalbereich schnell kommt der
Verdacht auf dass es sich um ein
Sexualdelikt handeln könnte Amanda wird
wie alle anderen zeugen von der Polizei
befragt logisch sie war als Erster am
Tatort wenn auch nicht im Zimmer von
Meredith sie hat die Polizei gerufen und
sie ist die Mitbewohnerin der Ermordeten
in den folgenden Tagen wird man sie
immer wieder vorladen und dieser
Zeugenaussagen entwickeln sich schnell
zu verhören und zu einem Albtraum Amanda
hat keinen Anwalt und die meiste Zeit
auch keinen Übersetzer ja und da will
ich jetzt ganz kurz einhaken am Ende
spricht zwar italienisch aber nach
eigener Aussage ungefähr auf dem Niveau
einer zehnjährigen sie liest zwar Harry
Potter Bücher was schon ziemlich
beeindruckend ist aber sie liest keine
Krimis und ihr fehlt damit natürlich das
entsprechende Vokabular was für ein
derartiges verhöhe notwendig wäre
die Beamten kommt zu der Überzeugung
dass am Ende mehr wissen müsste als sie
ihn erzählt immer wieder fragen Sie wer
ein Motiv haben könne sie müsste doch
jemanden kennen
und die Fragen steigern sich sie werden
zu Verdächtigungen als Raffaele der
ebenfalls immer wieder befragt wird sagt
dass er nicht mit völliger Sicherheit
sagen können dass Amanda die ganze Nacht
bei ihm gewesen sein was ja auch
irgendwie nur logisch ist denn er hat ja
in dieser Nacht auch geschlafen ne aber
nun glauben sie dass Amanda beim Mord
dabei gewesen sein dass sie die Tat
gesehen und alles wieder vergessen habe
ja und dass sie sie nur ordentlich
anschreien und einschüchtern müssen dann
würde ihr schon alles wieder einfallen
eine besondere Rolle spielt eine SMS die
Amanda in der Mordnacht an ihren Boss
schreibt den Barbesitzer Patrick Lumumba
sie arbeitet bei ihm als Bedienung und
hätte in dieser Nacht eigentlich Schicht
gehabt
aber in einer SMS und Männer schreibt
zurück alles klar bis später
für die Beamten ist das der Beweis sie
muss Lumumba in dieser Nacht getroffen
haben vermutlich bei sich zu Hause wo
der Bar Besitzer schließlich dann
Meredith tötete während Amanda dabei
stand oder sogar half anschließend
hätten sie das Fenster eingeworfen und
philomenas Zimmer verwüstet um so einen
Raub vorzutäuschen der ganze Verdacht
beruht letztlich auf diesem bis später
am Ende hat es auf Englisch ans Ende
Ihre Nachricht gesetzt also see you
later was den Ermittlern entgeht oder
was sie auf der verzweifelten Suche nach
verdächtigen ignorieren ist dass see you
later nicht unbedingt bis gleich
bedeuten muss es kann auch morgen in ein
paar Stunden oder so ähnlich bedeuten
alles zwischen gleich und bis bald
einmal Verhören sie immer mitten in der
Nacht ohne Anwalt und ohne Übersetzer
die Beamten brüllen auf sie ein sie habe
Amnesie sie solle sicher erinnern sie
müssen sich ja erinnern
so erzählt immer selber von diesen
Stunden das war sehr sehr beängstigend
und einschüchternd wer ist Patrick wo
hast du dich an diesem Abend mit ihm
getroffen hier steht dass du dich an
diesem Abend mit ihm getroffen hast war
er derjenige der es getan hat wer ist
Patrick mit wem ist er nach Hause
gegangen mit Ihnen
und im Laufe der vielen Stunden dieser
Art von Befragung fing ich an zu denken
dass ich vielleicht doch eine Amnesie
habe ich fing an zu denken naja ich habe
alle Erinnerungen daran dass ich in
dieser Nacht mit raphaele zusammen war
aber vielleicht sind das umgeschriebene
Erinnerung die ich versuche sie wissen
schon vielleicht will sich mein Verstand
nicht daran erinnern dass ich Zeuge
eines Mordes war vielleicht ist das der
einzige Grund warum diese Polizisten
mich anschreiben und irgendwann bricht
sie zusammen und sagt den Beamten exakt
das was sie von ihr hören wollen ja sie
habe sich mit Lumumba getroffen ja er
habe Meredith ermordet ja sie sei dabei
gewesen noch in der Nacht wieder ruft
sie die Aussage schriftlich doch der
Zettel verschwindet und taucht auch nie
wieder auf
vermutlich interessiert es die Ermittler
nicht sie haben jetzt einen Verdächtigen
den sie mit viel Tamtam verhaften können
das muss reichen
[Musik]
Patrick diallumumba bleibt nicht lange
in Haft Besucher seiner Bar geben ihm
ein wasserdichtes Alibi und die
Gerichtsmedizin findet dNA Spuren im
Körper von Meredith und die können sehr
schnell einem Kleinkriminellen namens
Rudi Herman greate zugeordnet werden der
ist bisher nur durch Diebstähle und
Einbrüche aufgefallen jetzt ist er der
Hauptverdächtige in einem Mordfall
Patrick Lumumba wird aus der
Untersuchungshaft entlassen vermutlich
ist Amanda knock sehr erleichtert als
sie das hört als Sie sicher sein kann
dass ihre Erinnerungen Stimmen und sie
die Nacht bei ihrem Freund verbracht hat
doch aus dieser Erleichterung wird
Entsetzen denn die Ermittler wollen sich
keinen Fehler eingestehen sie lassen die
Sache mit der SMS sang und klanglos
unter den Tisch fallen tauschen einfach
Patrick Lumumba gegen Rudi Guetta aus
und bleiben bei ihrer Story von der
Mittäterin
vermutlich auch getrieben von der
Öffentlichkeit für die der Fall eine
Sensation ist aber ich meine das ist
auch einfach wirklich ein krasser Fall
das ist eine Geschichte wie aus dem Kino
und sicher spielt es doch eine Rolle
dass sowohl Amanda als auch Meredith
wirklich hübsche junge Frauen sind
außerdem stammen sie auch noch aus gutem
Hause die Presse und das Internet die
drehen vollkommen durch
Amanda wird zum Sex-Monster gemacht die
ihren Freund rafaele und den
Kleinkriminellen Guide zu bezahlen
Sexspielen mit Meredith gedrängt hat und
zum Mord anstiftete als ich meredit
weigerte
foxynoxy lautet eine der Bezeichnungen
aus dieser Zeit sie wird der Engel mit
den eiskalten Augen genannt man kam
alles Mögliche aus ihrer Vergangenheit
hervor eine Geschichte über eine
vergewaltigungsfantasie die sie
geschrieben und ins Netz gestellt hat
ein Foto auf dem sie breit grinsend
hinter einem historischen
Maschinengewehr posiert wahrscheinlich
in irgendeine Ausstellung aufgenommen
Youtube-Video in dem sie betrunken ist
ja wenn Leute dir irgendwas an dichten
wollen dann werden sie im Netz einfach
so lange suchen bis sie irgendwelchen
Kram finden also irgendwas was sie in
ihrer Meinung bestärkt und alles was
entlasten könnte das wird
ignoriert oder uminterpretiert ja nehmen
wir nur zum Beispiel die Bilder von
Amanda raphaele vor dem Haus am Morgen
nach der Tat plötzlich will alle Welt in
diesen beiden Jugendlichen zwei Mörder
erkennen denen man ja ganz deutlich
ansieht dass sie genau wissen was dort
vor sich gegangen ist und die das alles
total kalt lässt aber wenn er in der
hysterisch geweint hätte und
zusammengebrochen wäre ja dann wäre das
natürlich nur gespielt gewesen um von
ihrer Schuld abzulenken oder ein Zeichen
für ihr schlechtes Gewissen oder was
auch immer zu liefern und natürlich
werden auch all ihre früheren
Beziehungen ans Licht gelehrt also ich
meine ja sie hatte Freunde vor raphaele
sie hatte Sex also ich meine sie ist
eine 20-jähr Studentin was erwartet man
und nicht dass er seine Rolle spielen
würde aber immer in der Knox ist keine
sexsüchtige fremdverteil sondern eher
schüchtern und vorsichtig ihren ersten
Freund hatte sie mit 19 und raphaele ihr
damaliger Freund ja der ist auch kein
wilder lehrt den Lover aus der Schublade
mit den erotischen Fantasien sondern der
studiert Computerwissenschaften und wird
wegen seines Aussehens oft als
italienischer Harry Potter beschrieben
na bevor wir jetzt zu sehr abdriften am
Ende sitzt inzwischen im Gefängnis
anfangs angeblich zu ihrem Schutz erst
Tage später wird sie vor einem Richter
gebracht es ist das erste Mal dass sie
einen Anwalt an ihrer Seite hat und es
ist das erste Mal dass sie hört was man
hier und inzwischen auch raphaele
vorwirft
sie Raffaele und Rudi hätten Meredith
für perverse Sexspiele einsparen wollen
als die sich weigerte habe Amanda sie
angegriffen der Staatsanwaltschaft
zufolge schlug sie ihren Kopf wiederholt
gegen eine Wand und habe versucht sie zu
erwürgen dann hätten Amanda und raphaele
sie auf Händen und Knien gehalten
während du sexuell missbrauchte Meredith
sei dann mit einem Messer getötet worden
und die drei hätten den Tatort
präpariert um einen Einbruch
vorzutäuschen der Staatsanwalt der geht
richtig auf in dieser Story er dichtet
den Angeklagten satanistische Praktiken
und was nicht alles an und welche
Beweise liegt dafür vor keine also klar
es gibt überall dNA Spuren und
Fingerabdrücke von Amanda auch im Zimmer
von Meredith aber ich meine ist ja auch
irgendwo logisch das war ja auch eine WG
mit ganz leeren Händen stehen die
Ankläger nicht da es gibt den Arsch
Spuren die auf Tag Beteiligung hindeuten
allerdings wird im späteren
Berufungsprozess deutlich dass diese
nicht verwertbar sind da die Ermittler
sehr unsauber gearbeitet haben und eine
Verunreinigung der Beweismittel nicht
nur nicht ausgeschlossen sondern sogar
sehr wahrscheinlich ist der zweite
wichtigste Punkt auf den sich die
Anklage stützt ist die Hypothese dass es
mehr als einen Täter gegeben haben
müsste anders sei der Tathergang nicht
zu erklären
am 20 November wird Rudi Grete in Mainz
verhaftet er ist ohne Fahrschein mit der
Deutschen Bahn unterwegs die daraufhin
gerufenen Polizisten dürften nicht
schlecht gestaunt haben als sie seine
Personalien überprüft haben und
plötzlich ein internationaler Haftbefehl
aufploppte Rudi wird nach Italien
überstellt sein Prozess wird von dem
gegen Amanda Knox und raffaeliscito
abgetrennt am 28 Oktober 2008 wird Erwin
Mortis zu 30 Jahren Haft verurteilt ein
Jahr später reduziert eine zweite
Instanz die Haftstrafe auf 16 Jahre der
Prozess gegen Amanda und raphaele
beginnt am 16 januar 2009 das sind die
beiden schon mehr als ein Jahr einhaft
am 5 dezember 2009 werden die beiden
wegen Mordes zu 26 bzw 25 Jahren
verurteilt im Podcast crime Junkies
erzählt Amanda es dauerte zwei Jahre bis
sich endlich ein Urteil erhielt ich war
davon überzeugt dass ich nach Hause
gehen würde das ist nur eine Frage der
Zeit war dass ich den Prozess
durchstehen musste daher war es für mich
niederschmetternd als ich herausstellte
dass dies nicht der Fall war und dass
die Theorie der Staatsanwaltschaft so
verrückt und unsinnig sie auch sein
mochte und so wenig Beweise sie auch
enthielt für die Leute fesselnd und
überzeugend genug war um mich für 26
Jahre ins Gefängnis zu stecken
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen wie man
sich in so einer Situation fühlt du bist
Anfang 20 du weißt dass du unschuldig
bist du hast schon zwei Jahre im Knast
gesessen und kannst dir ausrechnen dass
du Ende 40 bist wenn man Dich hier
wieder raus lässt ja und dazu hält dich
die halbe Welt auch noch für ein Monster
also natürlich gehen Amanda und Raffaela
im Berufung und natürlich werden sie in
der zweiten Instanz vom Vorwurf des
Mordes freigesprochen neue Gutachten
lassen von den hauptbeweisstücken der
Anklage praktisch nichts übrig
allerdings bestätigt das Gericht eine
dreijährige Haftstrafe für Amanda Knox
wegen Verleumdung wir erinnern uns sie
hat ihren Boss den Barbetreiber Patrick
dia Lumumba in einem stundenlangen
Verhör ohne Anwalt und Übersetzer
schließlich des Mordes bezichtigt die
Haftstrafe gilt aber als abgesessen denn
zu diesem Zeitpunkt war sie bereits vier
Jahre hinter Gittern Amanda wird
freigelassen und kehrt in die USA zurück
und dann beginnt in Italien ein dritter
Prozess wegen Mordes und was wirklich
krass ist das einzige neue Beweisstück
das ist eine Probe von solicitus
Küchenmesser von dem die Anklage
behauptet ist sei die Tatwaffe an dieser
Probe wird keine Spur von Meredith
culture DNA gefunden und trotzdem werden
die beiden erneut verurteilt Amanda
diesmal sogar zu 30 Jahren Haft wirklich
unglaublich aber wie ist sowas denn
möglich Amanda Knox antwortet auf diese
Frage da wir Menschen so intelligente
differenzierte Denker sind da gibt es
viele Möglichkeiten wie wir uns auf sehr
intelligente und subtile Weise
vorgaukeln können dass wir das richtige
tun obwohl wir es nicht tun und so wurde
jede neue Informationen auf die Sie im
Zusammenhang mit dem Fall stießen so
verdreht dass Sie Ihre bereits
bestehende Überzeugung bestätigte ich
denke dass mein Staatsanwalt sich für
einen guten Ermittler hielt für einen
guten Menschen und für jemanden der
seine Sorgfaltspflicht in diesem Fall
erfüllt hat und der Gedanke dass er eine
unschuldige Person nicht nur
strafrechtlich verfolgen sondern sogar
ein bisschen reinlegen könnte
ich denke dass er sich nicht glauben
konnte dass er so etwas tun könnte und
das ist der Grund warum er den Fall bis
ins letzte Detail verfolgt hat hier ist
ihm getan hat tja wenn man sich überlegt
was sie alles durchgemacht hat in der
Zeit dann finde ich diese Aussage schon
ziemlich differenziert ja auf jeden Fall
ich glaube viele würden da wohl kaum
noch so gute Worte finden um ihren
Ankläger zu verteidigen aber Mirko
vielleicht ist es jetzt Zeit zum Happy
End zu kommen oder vielleicht passt ja
auch eher das na so bad
endure ist tot Amanda Knox und Raphael
ist tot haben Jahre unschuldig in Haft
gesessen und ihr Ruf ist für immer
zerstört
wirklich glücklich kommt niemand aus
dieser Story raus aber immerhin am 27
März 2015 werden Amanda und raphaele
endgültig vom höchsten italienischen
Gericht freigesprochen wegen erwiesener
Unschuld doch die Erinnerungen die
verlorenen Jahre die Paparazzi die ihnen
immer noch folgen und die Menschen die
sie weiterhin mit Hassmails überschütten
die werden sie nie loslassen
Amanda Knox ist inzwischen mit einem
alten Schulfreund verheiratet und Mutter
etwas wovon sie in ihrer Haft träumte
und von dem sie dachte das ist nie
möglich wäre sie schrieb damals ihre
letters Touren an born child also Briefe
an das Kind dass sie vielleicht nie
haben würde inzwischen ist die
Journalistin und Aktivistin und setzt
sich für die Rechte von inhaftierten ein
und
sie macht Podcasts unter anderem
Podcast ah cool ja auf jeden Fall finde
ich eine coole Frau cool ja eiskalt nein
ein schönes Schlusswort Mirko vielen
Dank danke Toni und damit sind wir am
Ende der heutigen Folge angelangt
färben für diese Ausgabe viel gehört und
gelesen um uns gut auf diese Folge
vorzubereiten wer sich dafür
interessiert findet tausende von Quellen
und haben dabei besonders zwei Podcasts
geholfen in denen Amanda auch selbst zu
Wort kommt die Episode mördert Meredith
curture des Podcasts crime Junkie sowie
what even is justice von your wron About
und wenn ihr manchmal englischsprachige
Podcasts hört dann könnt ihr ja mal in
einen von Amanda Knox reinhören das z.B
der truth about the True Crime schön
dass ihr heute mit dabei wart und lasst
uns ein Like da empfehlt uns weiter und
vor allem hört mal wieder rein eure Toni
und euer Mirko